i'm max kaiser this is the kaiser report
hmm let's check in with
stacy well max the fed
is succeeding at what it wanted to do
according to this headline from
wolfstreet.com
dollars purchasing power dwindles to
another
record low fed is getting its
wishes so the latest data shows that
durable goods inflation
is at 3.3 percent food inflation is at
3.4 percent
and the consumer price index rose 1.7
percent in february from a year earlier
the fastest year-over-year increase in
12 months
right and the government is claiming
that in 2020 the inflation rate was
approximately 1.6 and they
are estimating that for 2021 the
official
rate of inflation will be about two and
a quarter percent
now if we were to look at the way
inflation was calculated
just 20 years ago without a lot of the
what are called hedonic adjustments
what we find is that the actual rate of
inflation
is over nine percent so
that chart from wall street.com is
showing clearly that your
purchasing power for the money in your
pocket
is losing at least 10 percent
per year in purchasing power that means
you've
if your wages are not increasing by 10
a year that means your standard of
living
is dropping and what we have in the
united states certainly
is a struggle to bring in
quote-unquote minimum wage to cr create
livable wages clearly those wages are
not
are not expanding so that quality of
life in america in
aggregate because of the money printing
which reduces purchasing power
is causing the standard of living in
america to
go down that is irrefutable and anyone
who debates that
is not looking at these very succinct
and clear
numbers yeah we're going to look at that
chart you mentioned from wolfstreet.com
that comes from data pulled from the
bureau of labor statistics which shows
the decline in the purchasing power of
the dollar
of course the money spigots were opened
and poured all over the place last year
in 2020
across the board so there was a huge
amount of
increase of money supply remember wages
went up by 14
last year income went up by 14 a lot
from government transfers so
a lot of people got a lot of money a lot
of it however was dispensed through
those ppp loans
which went to multi-billionaires and
billionaires and people worth hundreds
of millions of dollars got to
scoop up millions of dollars from the
taxpayers so there was a huge amount of
money that went out
uh but house prices went up 14.4 percent
as we covered
food prices are the supermarket prices
are going up by over five percent
some products and that's where that
hedonic adjustment comes in so like
beef was up by a hundred and eighty
percent since uh
last summer of course then people say oh
you know the
the the fed academic you know economists
will say well people stop buying the
beef and they buy chicken or pork
instead and and
therefore inflation has actually gone
down not risen
so the fed's mandate is to look at wages
and
prices right so here the the two
ingredients they're looking at they
want the purchasing power to decline
they want that that's what they want
they want inflation
um and the wages are always a difficult
thing because they don't want those to
rise they never want those to rise they
want
prices to rise but they don't want wages
to rise
the politically incorrect term for
consumer price inflation
which is what cpi tracks is
quote loss of purchasing power of the
consumer dollar
and thereby the loss of purchasing power
of labor denominated in dollars
and the purchasing power of the consumer
dollar
has dropped to a new all-time low in
february
according to the bls data today so here
is the chart purchasing power of
consumer dollar
index value not seasonally adjusted so
you see it from 2007 declining declining
declining as
of course since um you see the big dip
at first when the
financial crisis the great financial
crisis started
and uh money printing started to kick in
they slowed it down for a moment but as
you see
the the the decline in your purchasing
power continues
the the value of your labor continues to
drop essentially
what you can buy with your labor drops
yeah right what you can buy
for your labor drops right so that 15
income increase uh that you just
mentioned
is distributed in in unequally let's
call it
so that you've got this multiplying
effect on the asset side of the ledger
so for housing for example it's going up
by
considerably more but probably the best
mind who's looked at this
is michael saylor at microstrategy who
points out quite clearly that if you
look at an
inclusive uh aggregate of everything in
the economy that's the average person is
going to encounter including health care
housing education
food energy right down the list
the actual loss of purchasing power or
inflation per year
right now is between 15 and 20 percent
which would map
the the amount of money supply per year
now that's being pumped up into the
system
so no labor uh is going to keep up with
that
and uh only people who are speculating
in the asset market have any attempt to
keep up with that and that's why we see
so much money going into bitcoin because
it's a direct escape valve away from all
this
insane money printing but uh the actual
experience of day-to-day prices now
it's no longer easy to hide the fact
that food and energy
and housing are starting to meaningfully
impact
everybody in america who's not who's not
of let's say
the 100 million and above class where
they've got a hedge
in in terms of assets so that would
include
99.8 of the population
well it's going to be anybody who owns
any assets
including especially a home so if you
earn
75 000 a year and you have a four
hundred thousand dollar
property and it's gone up 15 this past
year
you've made a lot more than what your
stimulus check was
especially in terms of how our financial
system works is that
your equity in the property goes up your
ability to borrow
goes up and buy other assets going up in
value so
those who don't own any property
are as we pointed out in the last
episode of course
further and further away from being able
to acquire an asset from which they can
then leverage
and accumulate more assets but of course
we do have the situation whereby the
income went up
but your costs went down significantly
because there's a rent moratorium
on pretty much nationally mortgage
moratorium on pretty much nationally
that's part of the reason why uh house
prices are gone up so much
is there's some it's close to 14 of
properties
are in arrears on their mortgages
they're not paying it but they can't be
kicked out
so if this goes on for another year and
they keep on extending out
the um this moratorium because who knows
what happens when that
bill comes due the rent hasn't been paid
by some people for over a year now
so luckily i mean our largest landlords
in america
is uh blackrock is number one then we
have uh warren buffett these are
multi-multi-billionaires so they have
plenty of money but they're not getting
paid
so where that comes into play and what
when that cracks who knows like uh
that that could be a next catastrophe
but they seem fine right now maybe
blackrock is being actually
you know let's not say them but like
maybe some of these landlords are being
paid
through that same taxpayer facility of
these ppp loans and stuff like that
there's
programs from the taxpayer to pay for
this the same money printing
that that makes the the rent be paid but
by
somebody different and then you know
this
the the data on gold because you know
how do you how do you protect yourself
during these times right so how do you
acquire the assets that the fed or the
government is going to allow to go up in
price
and can't stop from going up in price
right
so we've talked over and over recently
about the bond vigilantes no longer can
exist
we we talked about the gold bugs that
used to also cause the government
to be honest like they weren't allowed
to print so much money they kept
integrity to the money printing machine
well
some data on the gold situation because
like 1.9 trillion dollars is now just
printed in this past
week and what does gold do down
right slowly then all at once bitcoin
flips gold at 550 000
so keep your eye on that but just
looking comparing
bitcoin to gold over the last 12 months
gold is now at zero percent it's fallen
back to where it was at the beginning of
the pandemic beginning of
four trillion printed by the government
last year
1.9 trillion printed today so that six
trillion dollars
has been printed in those 12 months 6
trillion the
the market cap of gold is only 8 to 9
trillion
so it's printed all of that nothing it
hasn't moved bitcoin is up
574 percent uh probably about in line
with uh money supply growth
right well it proves again that the
price of gold
does not enjoy free price discovery
uh whereas bitcoin does so bitcoin is
proving what many have said for years
going all the way back to the gold
antitrust action committee when we first
started talking about them 18 years ago
the price of gold is manipulated it
doesn't have true price discovery
and bitcoin does and bitcoin is showing
you what the money print is doing
now when you have assets on your books
and all the money printing is allowing
those assets to go up in price
is that good i mean you can't take your
house down to the grocery store and eat
it
right it's good because you can borrow
against it
yes and if interest rates are near zero
then you've got the ability to print
your own money i remember living in the
uk
during the housing boom people had their
house
tied to their bank account and every
month the value of the house was said to
go up another two percent
and the bank would let you borrow
another two percent right out of your
bank account
and charge you a low fairly low rate of
interest
and so interest rates have created a
divide
and and really the grounds for a new
civil war i think
because those who are allowed to get
those zero percent interest rates are
get them through political favoritism
not through merit those who are being
subjected to high interest rates
and and being cut out of the asset
market it that is also a political ploy
by those in power to get more
for themselves and to destroy the fabric
of the economy and that's
heading into serious trouble well i will
end this
like we'll wrap this up on a more
positive note in terms of what this
also could indicate in terms of bitcoin
versus gold
because uh the final chart as well is
bitcoin
at a new all-time high versus gold so
it's now 33 ounces
it cost to buy uh one bitcoin and that
is the transfer of what paul tudor jones
said why he's a gold investor but he's
also a bitcoin investor because bitcoin
is a bet on the future of humanity
and the future of human ingenuity and if
we are
you know part of the the problem with
the global financial system especially
in the u.s
disintegrating at the moment is the
boomers dying off
and their ponzi scheme disintegrating
whereas the millennials and generation z
coming online you know they're the
bitcoiners they're
this is them choosing to not
try to hold up the boomers ponzi scheme
they're saying
forget that like why go into like why
rack up a hundred and fifty thousand
dollars in student debts
so that grandpa might sell his house for
the fictional price he thinks he could
do it i'm not gonna do that right
right it's one country but two systems
geez where have i seen that before
all right we're going to take a break
and when we come back much more coming
your way
[Music]
welcome back to the kaiser report i'm
max kaiser time now to turn to
independent geopolitical analyst nick
giambruno
nick welcome back hey great to be with
you max the us government
just printed another 1.9 trillion dollar
stimulus on top of the 4 trillion dollar
stimulus last year
and yet gold is flat year on year
oh what's going on
yeah uh a lot of stuff is going on first
we have
you know people throw out trillion here
trillion there you gotta really
understand how big a trillion is
think about it uh do you know how long a
trillion
seconds ago were is back to 30 000
bc so if you're around 30 000 bc so if
you're talking trill this is how big a
trillion is it's incomprehensibly big
why hasn't gold responded i don't know
um
but it really it really should be um
bitcoin has
responded a lot hugely
as we record this bitcoin is up more
than 10 times way more than 10 times i
don't have the exact number off the top
of my head but it's up more than 10
times since
a year ago when all of this even more
money printing
started so uh it looks like a lot
of that uh store of value demand has
been
uh diverted to bitcoin i mean look at
bitcoin's market cap uh
change uh in over a year um that's
a lot of store value demand that might
have otherwise gone to gold so i think
bitcoin
is a part of the equation and one of the
drawbacks of gold of course is that it's
not really that portable
uh you right for the international man
uh what's been your experience trying to
cross border with some gold compared to
bitcoin well
uh i don't try to do it because i've
heard too many horror stories of
crossing borders with gold even uh small
amounts
so i personally don't do it um bitcoin
bitcoin
you know how do you know somebody has
bitcoin they just
can memorize 12 words and if you can
memorize 12 words you can store
billions of dollars worth of value so uh
there's no comparison there
yeah um the fact is that bitcoin is kind
of taking market away from gold
it's taking market away from fiat money
it also takes market away from the
so-called
altcoins and uh i guess the second
biggest
coin or one of the biggest altcoins out
there would be ethereum
and you've written a piece for casey
research quote a rube goldberg of
buzzwords
seven reasons to sell all your ethereum
today and buy
bitcoin right we don't usually talk
about altcoins but this piece was pretty
compelling tell us about it
yes well uh a lot of people who are new
to the space
they lump or don't know about the space
they lump bitcoin in with ethereum and
these altcoins but the reality is is
they're not even in the same
universe it's completely inappropriate
uh to lump them in
so um i don't think anybody is looking
at ethereum as a store of
anybody serious as looking at ethereum
as a store of value
so what i did in this piece is i just
took a deep dive on it and looked at
what is it what what really is it and
what attributes does it have
and compare them to bitcoin um in short
ethereum is not immutable
it can be censored it has a monetary a
flexible
arbitrary monetary policy that is hard
to audit
and is controlled by developers who
prefer inflation
um it has a net its network is
centralized its network infrastructure
is centralized
uh into this company called infl infura
so it's it's it's not decentralized in
the same way as bitcoin is
it has an unclear use case bitcoin has a
crystal clear use case it's a hard money
monetary system
that is accessible to anybody and
controlled by
nobody but what what real world pro it
works
bitcoin works in the real world and it
solves probably mankind's biggest
problem which is
storing and exchanging value that's what
bitcoin solves what is ethereum sold
uh as far as i can tell i haven't seen
it
anything built on ethereum uh that has
added any kind of economic value or
solve
any kind of uh real world problem no
it's clearly a pump and dump scheme
uh you know they have this enormous
pre-bind which is something again you
don't find with bitcoin but with
ethereum
they've got tens of millions of these
coins lying around and then they go
on these massive pump and dump schemes
it could be icos it could be ieos
it could be defy and now you've got this
nft craze it's just clearly a
money laundering pump and dump ethereum
led
it looks to me like money laundering and
i believe last i checked that's
illegal but um there's a lot of people
who are invested in it
and uh you've looked at the pre-mine
right it's pretty big
yeah well the ethereum pre-mine there's
a lot of problems with this i mean this
is
similar uh to the you know if people
don't know basically pre mine is
something where
people who are creating a cryptocurrency
create units of the cryptocurrency
before its mind
the first block is mine which is
traditionally how new supply
is entered into the system so ethereum
had an enormous pre-mine it's very
similar to the shenanigans you'll see
in the penny stock market with pump and
dumps where insiders give themselves
paper them up
to paper themselves up with cheap paper
and then dump it on onto the public
now the thing with ethereum that uh is
problematic with this
is its ownership centralization uh
the ownership of ethereum has been and
always
is and always has been centralized into
this
group of people who participated in the
free mine and to this day the pre-mine i
think it exists
as it is to the current supply of
ethereum is over 60
still to this day but there's another
problem with pre-mines is that they're
effectively
offerings of unregistered securities and
that tends to get the attention of
government agencies
yeah um you know a lot of people know
that
bitcoin cash and bitcoin satoshi vision
are exit scams
written by you know created and managed
by narcissists and
megalomaniacs but a lot of people don't
realize how
bad ethereum is and how risky it is and
what the probability is of them getting
shut down for selling unregistered
securities
but uh people do feel silly things and
so
i think that would fall into the
category of silly things
now with gold the central banks of the
world have all the pre-mine
you could say they own most of the gold
regulate the paper markets on which the
price is controlled
and uh you know gold in a lot of ways is
is another altcoin at this point it's
got so many drawbacks
which were not obvious because until
bitcoin came around people didn't really
focus on the fact that hey you know what
gold is actually a horrible store of
value in a medium of exchange
as a medium of exchange it's quite awful
um as a store of value
it's not it's not as bad as calorie
shells
or storing old telephone books like
peter schiff does he's got a whole
warehouse full of old telephone books
that i think his whole wealth is stored
in
but um you know it compared to bitcoin
it's really quite fall fall short
um now would you ever use gold as a
hedge
um unless you're a government or a
central bank i mean what where
you're big casey is big on gold is he
totally
going to switch over to bitcoin entirely
now or is or is casey still
stuck on gold nick well
the thing is is that uh what we're
interested what i'm interested in
is money what has the best monetary
properties we're not
particular i'm not particularly wedded
to anything i want something
that has the best monetary properties
and i want to look at that with open
eyes
and and and analyze that i'm not writing
off gold completely but
you're right looking going down the list
of all the attributes of money and money
is not that hard to understand
money is just something that stores and
exchanges value
that's all it is it's not complicated so
look at the attributes of gold and
bitcoin
and analyze them on its ability to store
and exchange value now most people can't
wrap their minds around this because
gold has really never had any
competition for thousands
of years of human history now it has a
serious competitor that could uh
dethrone it
and the most important attribute of gold
is uh
well look at the history of money the
history of money is the hardest money
wins bitcoin is now harder than gold
it's better at gold than gold and what i
mean by hardness is resistance to
inflation a lot of people think
hardness is something tangible it has to
be a metal it has to be something
physical
that's not what hardness means hardness
means hard to
produce so in other words resistant to
inflation
and why was gold money always it's
because gold was the one thing the one
commodity
that was most resistant to inflation
that's what made it a good money
bitcoin and how do you measure hardness
you measure hardness with the stock to
flow ratio
and that is what measures hardness and
bitcoin
now is harder than gold according to the
stock to flow
ratio so in that category gold's most
important attribute
bitcoin it beats it well
doug casey's so lucky he met you he'd be
wiped out by now
anyway uh nick you're in argentina
and uh inflation rate just hit 40
percent which is the definition of
hyperinflation we've been talking about
argentina for years we've
turned on a lot of people in buenos
aires and around argentina two bitcoins
saved their lives
probably thousands hundreds of thousands
of people what's going on in argentina
is about to crash for good
well you know it's uh nothing new under
the sun this is
a regular cycle it happens in argentina
almost like clockwork
the elect politicians that promise
freebies
the politicians print money to finance
the freebies and the currency collapses
and then they start the whole cycle all
over again
it's as predictable as the seasons uh of
the year here
and uh that's what's happening um so
argentines are used to it
most are very uh fluent in
having alternative ways to store value
and
and i mean look at the argentine economy
the argentine underground economy
unofficial economy
is huge relative to the above ground
economy so yes it's unfortunate
inflation hurts people it hurts the most
vulnerable people inflation is criminal
in my opinion even one percent
is is toxic it's a cancer one percent
inflation two percent inflation
as they want to have here in the u.s and
in europe
that's cancerous uh you should have no
inflation inflation is
a redu involuntary redistribution of
wealth towards the people creating the
money it's a horrible thing
so yes that's what's happening the good
news for argentines is they're used to
it they've seen it before
right yeah we've got about a minute or
so tell us about your concept of
oligarchic
money you've been writing about it what
do you mean
well actually uh i was referring uh to
parker lewis uh who wrote about what
uh vitalik buterin said about
uh bitcoins bitcoin's hard cap
this is where he showed his preference
for inflation he called the hard cap
on bitcoin oligarchic vitalik
the founder of ethereum and what parker
lewis said is
is that it's actually he's got it
completely backwards
uh inversion of reality it's not
oligarchic
what you have is a level playing field
when
anybody even the poorest person in the
world
can be on the same level playing field
as these new york hedge fund
billionaires by owning a piece of the
money supply that nobody can alter you
own a fixed piece of the money supply
that's not oligarchic that's very uh
equal that's a everybody has equal
rights there's no cantillon effect
in bitcoin in other words so um i think
vitalik buterin had it exactly wrong oh
yeah well if you look in the dictionary
under
charlatan there he is vitalik
with his little unicorn t-shirt
all right nick thanks for coming on the
cars report as always we got to come
down there and visit you in argentina
uh soon i hope thanks again for being on
the show
hey thanks max we'd love to have you all
right well that's going to do it for
this episode
of the kaiser report with me max kaiser
and stacy herbert like to
thank our guest nick giambruno you don't
have to say it like that but it sounds
better
until next time bye y'all
you